a seventeen-year-old in Kansas graduated
high school and then graduated from
Harvard University just a few days later
it's amazing yeah he studied for his
high school diploma and his bachelor's
degree at the same time I think that's
pretty amazing norm
okay who said that I did
oh I'm sorry that's said that's Tony our
cameraman Tony why did you just say yan
great question Conan I said yarn as a
way of expressing the fact that I am NOT
impressed by the thing you just
mentioned Tony you're not impressed by a
teenager graduating high school and
Harvard in the same week no that's only
two degrees huge whoop okay
I'm sorry what is huge what mean it's
like 10 big whoops it means two degrees
ain't squat because last week I got 17
degrees wait a minute
17 degrees yeah come on Tony that's
impossible impossible Richter rip off
your ears but shove up your nose hey hey
hey hey hey Tony calm down okay
[Applause]
Annie has a point 70 degrees in one week
seems pretty impossible oh yeah
I'll name all the degrees I got a
bachelorette of arts in the dog petting
Sciences from the Wyoming College of
canine fun a mister of arts and algebra
appreciation from over there University
a maester of flossing from george RR
martin almost dental school a freak
t-shirt and my name on a plaque written
ten baked potatoes in under five minutes
and bill's big bobs confusing barbecue a
horny winkler degree from the Western
University and Happy Days themed
pornography a double PhD in triple
economics in dinosaur genitalia from
super Harvard a dual degree in kickin
ass and takin names from master Tony
Kim's online Taekwondo studio for the
hygiene challenged a GED from the dirt
high school of heartburn sciences
monsters to grow from too many others
school a huge stuffed animal from that
game at the carnival where you squirt
the thing a BA and BS from fu a triple
Fieri degree from the flavortown academy
of poppers and tots a double degree in
shrinkage and yelling from nude opera
college a pH I'm feeling nice how you
feelin oh yeah from the Santa Cruz
College of the dispensary Arts at the
green I made up all that crap from you
just got Tony College or wasting your
time a degree in hate cone and I'm gonna
keep doing this until you tell me to
shut up from his cone and never gonna
tell Tony to shut up it would suck if he
did it University but degree in fine
have it your way Conan I'll keep saying
stupid crap if you're not gonna tell me
to shut up right Tony
shut up sure thing and congrats Conan
you just earned an honorary degree from
the puttin up with constant bullcrap
from Tony the cameraman
this is uh I want to say this is this is
a real honor there were so many people I
would like to thank you and we'll be
right back with Dana Carvey hey wait you
can't throw to commercial we got a great
show from the new movie secret life of
pets to comedian Dana Carvey is here
you